Das, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das war so ein kleiner Appetizer, das soll alle jetzigen Zweitligisten so richtig scharf darauf machen, man könnte sagen, es soll sie Heiden geil machen, darauf aufzusteigen, denn so kann das nämlich klingen. So war das im letzten Jahr beim ersten FC Heidenheim und auch zwei bis drei Vereine werden sie am Ende dieser Saison auch geschafft haben, am Ende dieser Zweitligasaison der Männer und damit hallo und herzlich willkommen in der Ligatur. Letztes Jahr haben wir –nee, nicht letztes Jahr, letzte Woche –haben wir dieses Format wieder aus dem Sommerschlaf aufgeweckt mit dem Blick auf die europäischen Top-Ligen der Männer. Heute wollen wir auf die zweite Bundesliga der Männer blicken und wir machen das im inzwischen etablierten Format mit drei Gästen, die einfach ein bisschen was zu ihren Vereinen erzählen. Und da begrüße ich zum einen Pike vom Kiel Podcast 1912 FM. Hallo Pike, schön, dass du da bist. Dann ist Sonja Riegel hier. Ihr kennt sie von Früff natürlich. Und heute können wir endlich mal über wen Wiesbaden sprechen. Da haben wir beide schon länger drauf gewartet. Hallo Sonja.
Hallo Max. Ja, da haben wir in der Tat schon ein bisschen drauf gewartet.
Ja, haben wir nicht noch in der letzten Erstligasendung, die wir zusammen gemacht haben, darüber noch geredet, ganz am Schluss? Ich weiß aber nicht mal, ob das in der Sendung gelandet ist und ob das schon off-air war.
Ja, aber kann gut sein, dass ich das ein bisschen versteckt erwähnt habe, dass das auch mal schön wäre.
Genau, also ich habe es mir auf jeden Fall so gemerkt. Und dann ist noch Benjamin Zurmühl hier zu Hertha BSC. Hallo Benny, schön, dass du da bist. Bevor wir loslegen, kurz der Hinweis, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbepayable und sponsorenfrei. Alles, was wir machen, finanzieren wir über euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und auch wenn euch so Einzelformate gefallen, dann unterstützt uns bitte, rasenfunk.de//supportersclub, da erfahrt ihr, wie das geht und ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. Aber dann wollen wir mal blicken auf diese Zweitligatabelle am Ende dieses Spieltags. Wir sind jetzt angekommen im Spieltag 6 und von oben grüßen uns Fortuna Düsseldorf und der HSV und dann schon, wie wir es alle erwartet haben, Pike, Heustein, Kiel. Und das, obwohl man am Wochenende wirklich eine harte Nummer vor sich hatte. Ich durfte live vor Ort sein im Millantor-Stadion und konnte dieses Spiel St. Pauli gegen Heustein sehen. Und ich habe Pike-Traumtore gesehen. Ich weiß gar nicht, welches das Schönste war. Gefühlt war auch jeder Schuss drin von St. Pauli. Ist das dann auch Teil der Erklärung, warum das mit 1 zu 5 so deutlich würde für Heustein?
Ja, also das Spiel fing denkbar schlecht an, dass unsere Abwehr komplett neu aufgestellt werden musste, weil Colin Kleinebekel, der ja für die U21-Nationalmannschaft debütiert hat, mit einem Infekt wieder kam und Erras sich einen Zeh gebrochen hat. Das heißt, die Innenverteidigung war komplett neu aufgestellt. Da hatte man dann schon mal so ein bisschen schlechteres Gefühl. Und ja, dann irgendwie nach vier Minuten nach einer Ecke wird der Ball da ins Eck gezimmert, außer der zweiten Reihe, irgendwie aus 25 Metern. Da dachte man schon so, na gut, St. Pauli noch keinen Heimtor geschossen diese Saison und dann gleich so eins, zwei Minuten später wird ein Freischuss direkt verwandelt. Und dann ging es eigentlich so weiter. Also vier der fünf Tore sind außerhalb des 16ers passiert. Und wenn man dann auch mal guckt beim Kicker, irgendwie Expected Goals-Werk von St. Pauli war unter eins. Und daraus machen sie fünf Tore. Also ja, das war so ein Spiel, das war ein komplett gebrauchter Tag für Kiel. Ich muss sagen, ich fand, Holstein war nicht mal richtig schlecht fußballerisch. St. Pauli hat auf jeden Fall verdient gewonnen, das muss man auf jeden Fall so sagen. Aber wir waren jetzt nicht irgendwie 5-1 eine Klasse schlechter, sage ich mal. Aber ja, da ging für St. Pauli alles einfach richtig gut, für uns alles eher schlecht. Dann ja noch der Vorfall in unserem Gäste-Block, dem Sanitäter-Einsatz, wo dann auch der Support komplett eingestellt wurde. Und ja, für Holstein war es dann im Endeffekt ein komplett gebrauchter Tag. Aber jetzt kein Spiel und auch kein Ergebnis, was einen irgendwie für die nächsten Spiele große Angst macht. Weil irgendwie war das wieder so ein Spiel, was man ein bisschen gesondert betrachten muss. Weil, wie gesagt, wenn du nach sechs Minuten, nach zwei Traumtoren so zurückliegst, ja, irgendwie kann man da nicht mehr viel machen.
War auch so ein bisschen der Vibe, den ich aufgenommen habe. Ich bin mit vielen Holstein-Fans zurückgefahren, weil ich musste direkt nach Abpfiff weiter, um dann gleich das nächste Erstligaspiel zu gucken, wegen der anderen Sendung, die ich noch hatte. Und logischerweise, direkt nach Abpfiff waren da viele Kielerinnen und Kieler in den U-Bahnen Hamburgs. Und die waren auch eigentlich relativ beruhigt und haben das eben auch so ähnlich bewertet, wie du das jetzt gesagt hast. Was ja aber auch, glaube ich, mit dem sonstigen Verlauf dieser Saison zu tun hat. Wie ist denn Holstein überhaupt auf den dritten Tabellenplatz gekommen? Man hat jetzt vier Siege, zwei Niederlagen. Das ist ja keine so schlechte Quote.
Nee, also der Saisonstart verlief besser als erwartet, weil ja wieder mal, was man ja von Holstein auch kennt, gefühlt die gesamte Mannschaft durchgetauscht wurde. Also 16 Spieler haben wir uns verlassen. Und ja, das ist dann natürlich eine riesen Wundertüte. Man hat viele spannende Namen geholt. Vorneweg natürlich Shuto Machino aus Japan. Und das hat dann ganz gut funktioniert. Man war voller Vorfreude auf das Braunschweig-Spiel, was dann zwar gewonnen wurde fußballerisch, aber wirklich sehr mau war. Das war dann so ein bisschen, okay, mal gucken, vielleicht geht es doch eher weiter wie letztes Saison. Aber dann das Spiel gegen Fürth gewonnen. Gegen Magdeburg haben wir dann zwar zu Hause verloren, aber auch guten Fußball gespielt. Und man muss sagen, Magdeburg einfach aktuell, glaube ich, spielerisch mit einer der stärksten Mannschaften der Liga. Da kann man dann auch mal verlieren. Ja, und dann 2-0 auswärts auf einen Freitagabend mit fast 3.000 Kielern irgendwie Schalke. 2-0, ja, schon eigentlich wirklich dominiert. Ja, das war dann wirklich ein extrem guter Saisonstart, hat nochmal wirklich alle Fans und auch die Mannschaft euphorisiert. Letzte Saison hatte man so ein bisschen das Gefühl, als wenn so Fans, Verein, Mannschaft, alles eher so ein bisschen sich auseinander gelebt hat, was diese Saison halt wieder jetzt wirklich zusammengewachsen ist. Und das hilft natürlich sehr. Und ja, jetzt nach dem Spiel gegen St. Pauli sind wir immer noch dritter, was ganz gut ist. Mit einer negativen Tordifferenz muss man natürlich dann auch erst mal schaffen. Da hatten wir aber jetzt natürlich auch Glück, dass HSV verloren hat und so. Und ja, also bisher kann man sehr, sehr zufrieden sein, dass die Mannschaft sich so schnell gefunden hat. Und unser Sportdirektor, der ja letzte Saison sehr in der Kritik stand, aktuell wirklich einen guten Job anscheinend gemacht hat.
Ja, da würde ich gerne gleich nochmal länger drüber sprechen. Das war aber auch der Eindruck, den ich dann im Stadion gewonnen hatte, dass neben den Traumtoren, die da St. Pauli hatte, auch einfach die Spielanlage von St. Pauli extrem unangenehm war für Holstein. Also sowohl gegen den Ball mit dem Pressing als auch im Spielaufbau. Da hat ja Holstein verschiedene Dinge probiert, hat ja umgestellt von Viererkette auf Fünferkette. Im Anlaufverhalten haben sie es verändert. Egal, was sie gemacht haben, es hat nicht funktioniert. Aber ich fand es interessant, dass man so viele unterschiedliche Sachen probiert hat. Und das hat ja wahrscheinlich auch damit zu tun, dass man jetzt eben eine größere Breite im Kader hat. Woher kommt denn das, dass Holstein jetzt schon wieder einen so krassen Umbruch hatte? Also ich habe es gerade nochmal verglichen. Im letzten Jahr waren es ja gar nicht so viele Wechsel im Vergleich zu diesem Jahr.
Ja, also einerseits natürlich, dass mit Finn Bartels, einer unserer besten Spieler, seine Karriere beendet hat und mit Fabian Reese, unser quasi nächster bester Spieler, weggegangen ist. Und dann hatte man einfach auch am Ende der letzten Saison so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass in dieser gesamten Mannschaft so ein bisschen die Luft raus ist, was bei vielen Spielern auch noch so ein bisschen an dieser gescheiterten Aufstiegssaison hängt, wo wir drei Match-Bälle am Ende vergeben haben, dann noch die Relegation zwar erreicht, aber die dann ja im Rückspiel dann leider verkackt haben. Und gerade im Hauke Wal hat man das gemerkt, das hat ihn einfach so sehr beschäftigt. Also letzte Saison war der irgendwie gar nicht so richtig bei der Sache, auch dann ja lange verletzt gewesen. Und irgendwie brauchte diese Mannschaft einfach mal diesen neuen Geist und deswegen wurden extrem viele Verträge auch nicht verlängert. Einen Spieler wie Simon Lorenz, da kam dann halt auch raus, dass der sich auch einfach verpokert hat, weil er so ein bisschen dachte, gut, jetzt bin ich der letzte Innenverteidiger hier bei Holstein Kiel, jetzt kann ich noch mal richtig Gehalt abkassieren, was nicht geklappt hat. Und ja, der ist ja jetzt in der dritten Liga bei Ingolstadt. Genau, und deswegen wurde es einfach so mal ein kompletter Neustart gewagt. Und ja, bisher hat es dann auch sehr, sehr gut geklappt. Wie gesagt, mit spannenden Spielern, Maschino einen Ivicic aus Serbien geholt. Mit Tom Rote, glaube ich, einem der größten Außenverteidiger-Talente, ausgeliehen, den man so kriegen kann. Was auch das, was mich wirklich beeindruckt hat. Und dann natürlich so was wie Colin Kleinebekel, der aus unserer U23 hochkommt, die letzte Saison gegen den Abstieg gespielt haben. Direkt Stammspieler, direkt U21-Nationalmannschaft, da direkt in die Startelf, jetzt auch getroffen. Also ja, so ein kleiner Shooting-Star aktuell. Da kommt einfach gerade sehr, sehr viel zusammen bei Kiel. Und aktuell macht es wieder sehr, sehr viel Freude. Weil letztes Jahr war es halt wirklich so, selbst die Spiele, die man gewonnen hat, waren meistens grauenvoll anzugucken. Und jetzt ist es wieder so, selbst wenn wir verlieren, kann man sagen, ey, ist nicht schlimm, aber die Mannschaft macht Spaß, der Fußball macht Spaß. Und das ist ja dann eigentlich so das Wichtige.
Und damit hat sich ja auch so manche Personalien nochmal neu bewertet. Also die ganze sportliche Leitung, glaube ich, steht aktuell in einem anderen Licht da. Weil du hast es angesprochen, also dieser Endspurt der Saison, das ist so ein bisschen untergegangen im Drama der sonstigen Liga. Aber ich hatte ein bisschen Kontakt mit Holstein-Fans. Mir hat nämlich jemand noch geschrieben, ey, du musst unbedingt in der nächsten Ligatur über Holstein sprechen. Da meinte ich, ja, ich weiß, was du meinst, aber da läuft noch so ein Ausstiegsrennen. Das müssen wir leider auch noch besprechen. Aber da war schon einfach sehr viel Unzufriedenheit da. Wie hat das denn jetzt den Blick verändert auf die handelnden Personen?
Ja, auf jeden Fall ins Positive. Ich sag mal, Marcel Rapp hat sich natürlich jetzt einige Pluspunkte erspielt, ist bei einigen Fans immer noch so mit Vorsicht zu genießen. Aber natürlich schon deutlich besser. Und Uwe Stöver, ich muss sagen, letzte Saison hatte er, fand ich, schon ein paar Spannetransfers, die halt dann nicht funktioniert haben. Aber ich habe ihn jetzt nie so schlecht gesehen wie einige Kiel-Fans. Und diese Saison bisher alles richtig gemacht. Und man weiß natürlich auch als Fußballfan, gerade im Internet, geht das natürlich sehr schnell vom Hofjagen zum bester Mann irgendwie und groß gefeiert. Aber aktuell macht er einen guten Job. Der Verein ist in ruhigem Wasser. Auch Trainer und Sportdirektor vom Standing her, sage ich mal. Da kann man sich, glaube ich, gerade nicht beschweren. Also da arbeiten alle ganz gut zusammen jetzt.
Ich habe da eine Nachfrage bei dem Uwe Stöver. Habe ich das richtig in Erinnerung, dass bei dem Maschinotransfer auch noch ein Spieler für die U23 auch gekauft worden ist aus Japan? Das fand ich auch ganz interessant für die Eingewöhnung. Sollte das nicht richtig in Erinnerung haben?
Genau, der hat schon in Deutschland gespielt, in der fünften Liga. Ich weiß gerade nicht, bei welchem Verein, aber der spricht halt fließend Japanisch und fließend Deutsch. Und der wurde dann quasi für unsere U23 verpflichtet, wie du sagst, um ihn die Eingewöhnung zu erleichtern. Ist passenderweise auch ein ganz guter Kicker noch. Das heißt, er spielt auch für die U23. Und ja, war dann natürlich ein ganz, ganz praktischer Move vom Verein. Das hatten wir damals aber schon mal bei dem Spieler Okugawa gemacht, als wir den ausgeliehen hatten. Hatte Holstein zumindest eine Familie gefunden an Kiel, die südkoreanisch kochen kann. Und damit er nicht so viel Heimweh hat, durfte er dann da jeden Tag irgendwie hin und heimische Nahrung zu sich nehmen. Und da ist der Verein dann wohl schon immer ganz gut hinterher, dass die Spieler sich wohlfühlen.
Okay, das habe ich jetzt zum ersten Mal gehört. Aber wirft er nochmal so ein interessantes Licht auf die Transfers. Also, wenn ich jetzt versuchen würde, eine Transferstrategie zu erkennen, dann wäre außer relativ jung die meisten Neuzugänge und eben mit Talent nach oben. Aber ansonsten erkenne ich da keinen gemeinsamen Nenner. Wie sieht denn das Scouting von Kiel aus? Man kann es ja immer nur von außen bewerten.
Also, einen gemeinsamen Nenner, den die meisten Spieler haben, ist, dass die mehrere Positionen abdecken können. Also, ein Ivicic, der ein Sechser ist, der kann aber auch sehr gut Innenverteidiger spielen. Remberg im zentralen Mittelfeld kann soweit auch Sechser, aber auch Achter weiter vorne. Sima Kalla von Osnabrück, der ja auch letztes Jahr einer der besten Drittligaspieler war, der aktuell bei Kiel jetzt aber noch nicht so Fuß fassen konnte, kann ja auch außen mittelsturmen. Also das ist so ein bisschen so das, was alle vereint und wo auch gerade defensiv geguckt wird, dass alle Spieler gefühlt alle Positionen abdecken können. Also ja auch ein Becker, der jetzt schon länger bei uns ist, kann Außenverteidiger, Innenverteidiger, ein Schulz, spielt das öfter, Sechser, Außenverteidiger, Innenverteidiger, also das wechselt immer sehr viel durch. Ich glaube, da wird sehr, sehr viel darauf geachtet, dass man versucht, mit einem Spieler zwei bis drei Positionen abzudecken, einfach dass man da sehr variabel ist und auch auf Verletzungen gut reagieren kann.
Ja, okay, stimmt. Guter Punkt. Aber ansonsten allein eben die unterschiedlichen Vereine, Göteborg, Zwickau, Zweite von Werder, Preußen, Münster, Borussia Dortmund und eben Schonabell-Mare bei Margino. Also da kommt wirklich alles zusammen bei euch sein. Da kann man in so manchem Wikipedia-Rabbit-Hole verhindern. Habe ich vorher gemerkt, als ich mich so ein bisschen durchgeklickt habe, dann gemerkt habe, okay, leider reicht dafür jetzt die Zeit nicht mehr, weil wir nehmen schon heute auf und ich erst in einer Woche. Was soll denn die Rolle von Kiel sein, die man in der Saison spielt? Also auch jetzt, wo man ja letztes Jahr durchaus eben die Unzufriedenheit auch gespürt hat im Umfeld. Was glaubst du, was will man eigentlich erreichen in der 2. Liga?
Ja, also so dieser Grund, die Grundvorgabe von Kiel ist ja quasi immer, dass sie sagen, wir wollen gerne mindestens einen Platz besser werden als in der Vorsaison. In der Vorsaison sind wir ja noch achter geworden, warum auch immer, aber irgendwie sind wir am Ende auf Platz 8 gelandet und ich kann mir vorstellen, gerade jetzt nach dem guten Saisonstart, dass schon so die Top 6 ein gutes Ziel ist für Kiel. Man muss natürlich gucken, wo jetzt die Reise hingeht, weil auch gerade die Siege, die wir eingefahren haben, waren halt jetzt gegen Teams, die doch eher unten angesiedelt sind in der Tabelle, auch wenn es jetzt Schalke ist, aber auch Fürth und Braunschweig. Deswegen, da muss man mal gucken, wo die Reise hingeht, aber ich denke mal, Top 6 ist jetzt schon so ein internes Ziel, gerade nach dem guten Saisonstart.
Und hast du das Gefühl, dass sich Kiel, also dass sich auch Holstein in Kiel jetzt so richtig etabliert hat? Ich weiß, dass man rund um die Relegation damals gegen den 1. Elf zu können, da war das noch ein Thema, weil da war der THW, also Handball eben auch wieder sehr erfolglich, ist ja generell ein sehr erfolgreiches Team, hatte jetzt aber in den letzten Jahren auch ein bisschen Konkurrenz bekommen. Da müssen wir jetzt nicht zu sehr in den Handball einsteigen, aber da wurde es damals thematisiert, dass eben anders als in anderen Städten der Fußball jetzt gar nicht so die allererste Sportart immer ist in Kiel selbst. Hat sich da was geändert in den letzten Jahren?
Ja, also ich würde jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen, dass es direkt die Nummer eins ist. Ist halt aber auch schwer zu sagen jetzt bei THW Kiel und Holstein Kiel, aber insgesamt findet Holstein Kiel schon einen großen Anklang hier in Kiel, gerade weil jetzt auch so die nächste Generation an Fans groß wird, die Holstein Kiel als richtigen Profiklub, als Zweitligis kennt. Es gibt jetzt kleine Kinder, die im Holstein Kiel-Trikot herumlaufen. Das gab es halt die ganze Zeit nicht, als wir in der vierten und fünften und das Beste war halt immer so dritte Liga. Das merkt man dort doch schon. Eine Zuschauerzahl bewegt sich halt immer so, jetzt aktuell so bei 11.000, 12.000. Letzte Saison wurden natürlich auch einige Event-Fans, Erfolg-Fans noch mal vergrault. Die kommen jetzt so langsam wieder. Insgesamt muss man aber sagen, der harte Kern wird immer größer. Wenn man dann halt betrachtet, was wir an Auswärtsfans zum Beispiel prozentual mitbringen, wenn man das mit der Heimzuschausschaft vergleicht, also 12.000 zu Hause, aber 3.000 Auswärts auf Schalke Freitagabend, das ist dann halt schon ganz ordentlich. Deswegen, Holstein Kiel findet immer größeren Anklang hier. Umso länger wir jetzt halt natürlich in der 2. Liga sind, desto größer wird das auch alles und desto mehr merkt man das auch. Das ist halt so das, was viele Vereine in Holstein halt vorweg hatten. Die haben halt alle schon mal ihre große Zeit in den letzten 20, 30 Jahren gehabt, sag ich mal. Ja, und das muss Holstein Kiel jetzt langsam aufholen.
Jetzt lasst Benni halt in Ruhe, wir reden erst später. Oder hast du von wehen Wiesbaden gesprochen?
Auch, ja.
Also es ist jetzt das siebte Jahr in der 2. Liga eigentlich irre, dass das noch gar nicht so lange ist, weil gefühlt ist Holstein schon viel länger mit dabei. Und glaubst du, dass man jetzt auch sollte diese Saison noch eine Delle bekommen? Und davon ist ja auch zu gehen, niemand zieht so durch und du hast ja auch schon ein bisschen relativiert diese Anfangsphase. Bisher war ja Kiel eigentlich kein kein unruhiger Verein, aber eben in der letzten Saison habe ich das so zum ersten Mal gespürt, dass da eben auch durchaus auch Rapp und Stöber in Frage gestellt wurden. Glaubst du, das hat sich verändert jetzt mit diesem guten Start?
Ein bisschen, ja. Aber ich sag mal, wenn jetzt so drei, vier schlechte Spiele in Folge kommen würden, dann wäre zumindest der Trainer doch schnell wieder in der Kritik, gerade weil er gerne halt die gleichen Fehler jetzt halt immer noch macht. So er fängt ja immer gerne mit dieser Dreier-Innverteidigungskette an und stellt dann irgendwann, wenn er merkt, das klappt nicht auf Viererkette um. Das hat er letztes Jahr schon immer gemacht. Und allgemein, von der Art passt er gefühlt nicht ganz so nach Kiel. Er bemüht sich aber, das muss man schon sagen, und bringt auch immer viele kleine Sachen, die bei den Heutztschen-Fans gut ankommen. Zum Beispiel, dass er halt bei der Pressekonferenz ja nochmal erwähnt hat, dass Heutztschen-Kiel gegen St. Pauli kein Nordderby ist, wie es ja gerne in den Medien erwähnt wird, sondern ein Nord-Duell. Und sowas finden dann die Fans natürlich immer ganz gut, wenn da ein Trainer auch drauf achtet auf so Kleinigkeiten. Ja, sportlich gesehen schwierig. Ich glaube, er hat noch einen schwierigen Stand, aber ist auf einem guten Weg, seinen Ruf zu verbessern, sage ich mal.
Okay, und was sind so kleine Dinge, die ein Trainer noch so mitbringen muss, damit Kieler-Fans sich freuen, außer Nord-Duell statt Nord-Durbel? Die Kieler habe ich auch schon mal gemacht, das habe ich auch schon gelernt auf die harte Tour.
Ja, eigentlich ist ja in Kiel dann auch so ein bisschen, was halt auch so in Bremen beliebt ist, diese Gelassenheit, norddeutsche Ruhe. Ole Werner war ja hier sehr beliebt, auch weil er so ein bisschen mehr so der Kumpeltyp ist. Da ist Rapp wohl relativ anders und ein bisschen mehr auf Autorität. Ich glaube, das sind so die Sachen, die einen Trainer schnell beliebt machen. Und ansonsten ist es, glaube ich, wie bei jedem anderen Verein auch, durch sportliche Erfolge und Fußball der Spaß macht. Und dann wird das, glaube ich, schon.
Dann wird das, glaube ich, schon. Also wir werden genau gucken, wie es mit Kiel weitergeht. Aktuell Rang 3 und damit auch der erste Verein hier in der Runde, den wir besprochen haben. Dann folgen dahinter Hannover, Magdeburg, St. Pauli, Kaiserslautern, Rostock, Karlsruhe. Und dann kommt schon Sonja, der SVW in Wiesbaden. Und ich habe jetzt die ganze Zeit überlegt, kann ich jetzt von dem, was wir gerade über Marcel Rapp gehört haben, eine Brücke bauen zu Markus Kautinski, in Gelsenkirchen geboren? Aber mir fiel irgendwie nicht so recht eine Parallele auf. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da was übersehen habe. Aber ja, was ist denn zum Start von Wien-Wiesbaden zu sagen und vielleicht auch zu Kautinski?
Das sind gleich mal viele Fragen. Kautinski, würde ich sagen, vielleicht kann man so ein bisschen das rübernehmen, dass er auch relativ gelassen ist, rüberkommt und das alles so ganz gut moderiert. Das würde ich jetzt als Parallele da so ein bisschen von mitnehmen. Das ist natürlich jetzt auch einfach nur ein paar Worte reingeworfen. Aber ich glaube, wir vertiefen es ja gleich noch ein bisschen. Und ja, zum Start mit dem Start kann man absolut zufrieden sein. Du hast jetzt acht Punkte aus sechs Spielen, stehst im Mittelfeld, wo du ja eigentlich auch –also das ist eigentlich das, was sie erreichen wollen am Ende, auch wenn sie immer so schwammig sind in ihren Aussagen, was sie wollen. Aber damit wäre ja jeder top zufrieden. Und wenn du zurückgehst, letztes Mal Zweite Liga 2009, da war es ein Punkt nach sieben Spielen. Und deswegen wird niemand darüber meckern, was sie jetzt bisher erreicht haben.
Und mit einer bemerkenswerten Effizienz allein, was quasi das Tore-Punkte-Verhältnis angeht. Wien-Wiesbaden hat eine Tordifferenz von 6 zu 6 und daraus eben zwei Siege, zwei Unentschieden, zwei Niederlagen. Kann man sich sehr gut alles merken. Also spektakel ist es jetzt gerade, aber noch nicht, oder habe ich da was verpasst?
Nein, das soll es aber auch gar nicht sein. Du sagst, 6 Tore in 6 Spielen, sie haben tatsächlich in jedem Spiel genau ein Tor geschossen. Das klingt ja schon so, als würde man als neutraler Beobachter, und davon wird es jetzt in dem Fall einige geben, sagen, was soll ich mir das angucken? Aber eigentlich ist es genau diese Spielweise der Mannschaft. Also zu sagen, okay, wir sind jetzt hier Aufsteiger, wir sind jetzt hier der Underdog und wir gehen jetzt eben nicht auf dieses Spektakel. Das war auch da wieder die Parallele zu 2019. Da wollten sie im Prinzip diesen Spektakel-Fußball aus der 3. Liga, eine Liga höher mitnehmen und da genauso weitermachen. Und haben dann halt gerade am Anfang die Hucke vollbekommen. Und sich dann nur langsam stabilisiert. Jetzt sind sie von Anfang an da so stabil reingegangen. Erstmal die Defensive und dann mal sehen, was wir mit Nadelschichten nach vorne machen können. Und ja, wie du sagst, sind nicht viele Tore, aber es ist sehr viel dabei rumgekommen. Und man muss ja sagen, Gegentore haben sie auch noch nicht so viele.
Genau, eben auch genau sechs. Und dabei auch ein spektakulärer Sieg mit dabei. Also ich denke, das werden viele Hörerinnen und Hörer auch mitbekommen haben. Dieser zweite Spieltag –es tut mir leid, Benny, da müssen wir dich kurz mit reinholen –wo eben Wien-Wiesbaden beide Hertha auswärts sehr spät mit 1 zu 0 gewinnt. Wie ist es denn, Gegner von Wien-Wiesbaden zu sein? Oder wie ist Wien-Wiesbaden als Gegner, meine ich jetzt, Benny?
Ich muss sagen, ich habe Wien-Wiesbaden auch sehr unterschätzt und das habe ich in den Spielen auch gemerkt, weil ich die Mannschaft mir angeguckt habe und gedacht habe, hu, da kenne ich dann doch relativ wenig Spieler. Aber ich glaube, das ist dann irgendwo auch die Stärke der Mannschaft, so von meiner Betrachtung von außen. Sie funktionieren einfach als Einheit sehr, sehr gut und machen die Basics sehr gut. Also Standards verteidigen, generell verteidigen, sie haben sehr viel Geduld und dann auch immer wieder Nadelstiche eben nach vorne, wie Sonja das gesagt hat. Also mir hat im Spiegel hier der Lee sehr gut gefallen, der, glaube ich, neu zugang ist, korrigiere mich, wenn ich falsch liege. Der hat immer wieder in einzelnen Aktionen das gut gemacht und eben genau das, was du dann brauchst, diese Entlastungsangriffe mal gebracht und eben große Geduld, große taktische Disziplinen, was die Defensive bald angeht. Deswegen ist Wien-Wiesbaden vielleicht individuell eine der schwächeren Mannschaften, aber im Kollektiv definitiv eine Mannschaft, die man nicht unterschätzen darf, so wie ich es getan habe.
Wobei, ich glaube, man muss zu dem Hertha-Spiel sagen, es war ja im Prinzip dann ein klassisches 0 zu 0. Also dieser Lucky Punch, dass du da in der Nachspielzeit mit zweimal Forsten aus dem Hinterhalt dieses Ding da reinmachst, das muss ja nicht passieren in dem Spiel.
Das stimmt, aber wenn du aus einer Bundesliga kommst mit Teams wie Union Berlin und dem FC Augsburg, dann bist du solche kuriosen 0 zu 1-Jährlangen halt irgendwie gewohnt.
Es hat besser zu Hertha gepasst als zu Wien-Wiesbaden. Vielleicht hat es auch zu Wien-Wiesbaden gepasst. Viele haben Wien-Wiesbaden nicht so auf dem Radar gehabt. Was haben wir denn verpasst in den letzten Jahren, Sonja? Das ist jetzt natürlich eine schöne Frage, wenn wir nur eine Viertelstunde haben.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. In den letzten Jahren ist es jetzt auch wieder groß. Wahrscheinlich gehst du eher so auf die Drittliga-Jahre. Diese Zweitliga-Saison hatten wir vielleicht noch so ein bisschen im Hinterkopf. Sie kommen hoch, wie gesagt, verkacken den Start und hatten damals ja auch erst mal von den Neuzugangen her nicht so viel und haben dann nochmal nachgelegt, haben Stefan Eichner geholt, Heinz Lindner. Das war aber, als sie schon einen Rückstand hatten. Dem sind sie nachgelaufen und am Ende abgestiegen. Dann war es eigentlich so ein bisschen die Frage, wie macht man weiter, macht man einen kompletten Neustart in der dritten Liga? Da haben sie sich erst mal dagegen entschieden. Sie haben ja damals am Trainerfest gehalten, Rüdiger Rehm noch, mit ihm eine Saison gespielt. Dann sind sie in die nächste Saison gegangen und haben ihn dann im Oktober entlassen. Dieser Zeitpunkt ist mir bis heute ein Rätsel. Selbst wenn man heute sagt, was sie da aufgebaut haben, ist ja gelungen bisher. Aber dieser Zeitpunkt war sehr seltsam. Ich hätte gedacht, vielleicht sagen sie nach der Zweitliga-Saison, wir machen hier einen Cut, oder nach dieser nächsten Drittliga-Saison, dass sie sagen, wir verändern das jetzt einfach mal. Das war ja relativ lang dann auch, fast fünf Jahre hier. Aber dann kam eben Kowcinski und dann hat sich das auch erst so ganz langsam eingespielt. Diese Saison, die er dann zu Ende gemacht hat, wenn man zu Ende überhaupt sagen kann, wenn jemand im November übernimmt, die ist ja dann eigentlich auch ausgelaufen. Also da waren ja dann keine großen Höhen und Tiefen mehr. Da gab es nichts mehr zu reißen, gar nichts. Und dann war es eigentlich kein so großer Umbruch im Sommer. Also er hat wirklich versucht, mit dem, was da ist, daraus ein Team zu formen. Und das ist ihm ja dann auch ganz gut gelungen, muss man sagen, und dann waren sie doch wieder obendran. Und ich glaube, das dramatische Ende, das hat dann wirklich jeder mitbekommen. Und wenn es nur darüber war, wie Bielefeld abgekackt ist in den Relegationen. Die Party, die es davor schon gab, als der Aufstieg vermeintlich feststand und dann Osnabrück hochgegangen ist und so. Das hat natürlich mit dem Team aber auch was gemacht. Also ich war eben bei diesem Spiel, da war ich als Presse da, als sie dann alle da schon standen und alle auf dem Rasen gefeiert haben. Und wenige Leute hatten überhaupt noch Internet. Und wir oben auf der Presse-Tribüne hatten das halt noch. Und haben dann gesehen, okay, jetzt kommt gerade rein, Osnabrück hat halt gewonnen und die feiern da unten alle. Und Stadionsprecher hat durchgesagt, ja, dann alle in einen schönen Sommer, wir sehen uns in der zweiten Liga. Und sowas kann ja ein Verein auch irgendwie oder Spieler auch erstmal brechen. Und du musst ja dann zur Relegation irgendwie wieder bei dir sein. Aber ich glaube, da hat es Kozinski ganz gut gemacht. Er hat danach erzählt, sie haben sich getroffen dann wieder zwei Tage später zum Training, haben gesagt, was haben wir erlebt? Die haben sich alle gegenseitig die lustigsten Geschichten erzählt, was sie mit Fans auf dem Rasen da unten beim Feiern erlebt haben. Dann haben sie gesagt, das wollen wir jetzt wieder, das wollen wir jetzt wirklich haben, diesen Erfolg. Und dann sind sie durch die Relegation gelaufen und hat ja dann ganz gut geklappt. Das wäre jetzt so die Kurzzusammenfassung, wie Wien da wieder gelandet ist, wo sie jetzt gelandet sind.
Ja, und es war ja vor allem die letzte Saison auch –also da war wieder viel geboten, so wie man eben Wiesbaden damals, fand ich, in der Aufstiegssaison schon erlebt hat. Also allein die Tordifferenz, 71 Tore geschossen, 51 kassiert, also da war Action gegeben. Und das war aber schon noch mal eine Weiterentwicklung zum zweiten Kautschinski, ja. Was hat sich denn in der Mannschaft verändert und welche Veränderungen müssen wir jetzt noch quasi besprechen? Wir werden jetzt dann über die zweite Liga sprechen, weil ich meine, so manchen Transfer hat jeder mitbekommen, weil da wurde sehr medienpräsent begleitet. Aber Wien-Wiesbaden stand ja auch vor der Aufgabe, eben Spieler zu ersetzen und sich jetzt eben anzupassen auf die zweite Liga. Und so wie das bis jetzt klingt, ist es ja eben genau der Unterschied zum letzten Aufstieg. Diesmal eben nicht so hurra nach vorne und so weiter, sondern erstmal defensive Basics gut machen und dann gucken, wie viele Punkte man damit kriegt.
Ja, also was ich aus dem Verein so gehört habe, war, dass sie dieses Mal auch sicherer waren, dass sie den Aufstieg schaffen oder dass sie da oben so lange dabei sind, dass das halt realistisch ist und dass sie mit ihren Transfers dann entweder schon so vorarbeiten oder entsprechend warten. Also, weil beim letzten Aufstieg, da hatten sie sehr viele schon vorher verpflichtet und hatten gar nicht mehr so den Gedanken, ob sie es vielleicht noch schaffen können. Und dann hast du die Leute unter Vertrag und so. Und das haben sie diesmal ein bisschen schlauer vorgebaut. Was aber eigentlich ein Problem war, du hast ja teilweise die Abgänge schon gerade so verklausuliert angesprochen. Das war ja nicht nur Hollerbach, bei dem sich das lange abgezeichnet hat und spätestens durch den Auftritt in der Relegation ja klar wurde, dass den jetzt irgendwie wirklich gefühlt jeder haben will. Aber es sind ja auch so Leute gegangen wie Ezee und Ghulain, die sind ja zu direkten Konkurrenten in der 2. Liga gewechselt. Das muss ja auch erstmal verdauen. Dann ist der Kapitän gegangen, weil er gesagt hat, der wird gerne nochmal was Neues sehen. Und der ist tatsächlich zu einem Verein nach Finnland gegangen, Johannes Wurz. Also das war nicht so was Neues sehen und auf einmal schlägt er in sein Hausen wieder auf, sondern der hat wirklich ein neues Abenteuer nochmal gesucht. Und die musste er dann auch erstmal ersetzen. Und das ist ihm, glaube ich, teilweise schon ganz gut gelungen. Also Lee habt ihr ja gerade angesprochen, der da ja im Mittelfeld ziemlich gut wirbelt. Da haben sie auch noch einen sehr guten Backup, wie ich finde, mit Nick Betzner, den sie aus Belgien geholt haben. Der hat sich halt früh verletzt in der Vorbereitung, aber der kann auf dieser Position, glaube ich, auch einiges reißen. Und eigentlich so der Königstransfer bisher ist Markus Matießen, der hinten jetzt den Abwehrchef gibt und der da wirklich konsequent alles wegräumt. Das ist ja eine richtig fiese Position, wenn du bei einem Aufsteiger da hinten drin stehst. Das macht er bisher wirklich richtig stark. Mal sehen, ob es reicht. Es ist wirklich so, wie Benny gerade gesagt hat, es ist wirklich eigentlich das Kollektiv. Dass Kocinski die so einstellt, dass sie wirklich als Kollektiv funktionieren. Und da ist es dann gar nicht so wichtig, dass du irgendwelche Starspieler hast oder so. Das ist, wie ich auch vorher schon gesagt habe, dass er eigentlich auch, als er gekommen ist, dann war ja relativ schnell die Winterpause, wo man denkt, er macht das jetzt, weiß ich nicht, wie früher Felix Maggert und holt irgendwie aus jeder europäischen Liga aus der zweiten Liga drei neue und schmeißt die ganze Mannschaft um. Und das ist eben nicht passiert. Sondern es war eher sein Ding, wie stelle ich das um mit denen, die ich habe. Und das führt er eigentlich nur konsequent weiter gerade.
Klingt ehrlich gesagt auch so ein bisschen, als hätte sich Marcos Kocinski verändert. Oder ich habe ihn bisher ein falsches Bild von ihm gehabt. Aber so beim KSC und bei St. Pauli, da habe ich ihn durchaus auch fordernd erlebt. Und hatte eben auch das Gefühl, da ging es ihm auch darum, mit dem Stil seiner Mannschaft etwas darzustellen. Also es war damals auch so ein Trend, dass es so gewisse Trainer gab, die haben eben so einen Stil geprägt. Also Tim Walther, Ralf Hasenhüttl war so einer der Vordenker davon. Und da hatte ich das Gefühl, Kocinski ging es ähnlich. Und wir alle wissen ja, das lief immer so, ja geht so. Also da waren immer gute Phasen mit dabei. Aber er wurde dann eben auch immer aus guten Gründen entlassen. Das, was du jetzt alles erzählst, das klingt ein bisschen verändert. Oder war mal ein Bild von ihm vielleicht falsch?
Ich habe jetzt natürlich nicht so die Einsichten in die Vereine von früher. Aber ich weiß nicht. Aber du hast ja eben auch gerade die Drittliga-Bilanz genannt. Da war es jetzt auch nicht so, dass sie nur hinten drin standen und keine Tore kassiert haben und vorne mal eins geschossen oder so. Ich glaube, das Wichtige ist, dass du dich halt auf die Liga einstellst, in der du spielst und darauf einstellst, was du hast und was du mit den Leuten machen kannst. Ich glaube, das ist das, was er sehr gut beherrscht. Es ist jetzt nicht so, ich habe den Stil und jetzt ist das immer so. Wir haben wirklich von Anfang an gedacht, als er kam, okay, wird das jetzt so hinten reinstellen. Das ist alles nicht mehr Spektakel, weil unter Rehm war es ja einfach ein Megaspektakel immer. Das ist ja das, was du auch gerne anguckst. Aber am Ende guckst du auch vor allem als Verein am liebsten die guten Ergebnisse an. Ich glaube, da hat er sich sehr gut darauf eingestellt und jetzt einfach aus dem, was er hat, die beste Zweitligamannschaft zu formen.
Und so richtig bewerten kann man es ja dann oft eh erst im Nachhinein, wenn dann ein Trainer auch wieder weg ist und man sieht, was machen andere Trainer mit ähnlichen Spielern. Was uns ja auch zu der Mannschaftszusammenstellung bringt. Du hast ja schon ein bisschen Einblick gegeben. Ich würde sagen, hohe Kreativität bei den Transfers. Zum Teil auch mit Leyen gearbeitet. Also Lasse Günther zum Beispiel geliehen von Augsburg und Jun-Yu Li von der 2. von Bayern, den du ja auch schon genannt hast. Und dann ist bemerkenswert, dass man schon seit vielen Jahren fast gar nichts in Transfers investiert. Und das hat man ja auch nicht dieses Jahr gemacht, wo man zwar nicht wusste, wann und wohin Benedikt Hollerbach wechselt, aber man wusste, dass er wechselt. Man wusste auch, dafür kriegen wir ein bisschen Kohle für. Erklär uns doch mal so ein bisschen, wie in Wiesbaden auf dem Transfermarkt agiert. Ich lese hier Nico Schäfer als Geschäftsführer Sport, Paul Fernie ist der sportliche Leiter. Wie teilen die sich das auf? Wer ist dafür zuständig, die Kader zusammenzustellen?
Im Prinzip ist das erstmal der Sportdirektor. Das ist eigentlich sehr bemerkenswert, der immer in den Spielerverpflichtungsmeldungen zitiert wird. Da ist nie eine Trainerstimme drin, komischerweise. Das ist immer Sportdirektor, Geschäftsführer meistens auch noch. Aber da kann man sich dann ungefähr vorstellen, wer da am tiefsten drin ist. Aber in der 3. Liga musst du ja sowieso so rangehen, dass du sagst, du holst hier jüngere Spieler ran, arbeitest auch mal mit Leinen und sowas. Das ändern sie jetzt auch nicht für die eine oder andere 2. Liga-Saison, die jetzt mal dabei war. Damit sind sie auch gut gefahren. Wir versuchen es natürlich auch immer, dass sie als guter Ausbildungsverein gelten, dass sie auch jüngere Spieler bekommen, auch wenn sie wissen, die bleiben jetzt nicht ewig bei uns. Wenn du da Leute für einen 7-stelligen Betrag verkaufen kannst, ist das ja auch richtig geil. Davon rücken sie eigentlich nicht so wirklich ab. Wenn du sagst, kreatives Scouting oder so, dass sie vor allem in den Skandinavien-Markt gucken oder in den Schweden-Denemarkt, da waren eigentlich immer mal wieder welche dabei in letzter Zeit. Also auch so Piake Jakobsen ist ja auch aus Dänemark gekommen. Da muss man ja auch ein bisschen kreativer sein. Da kriegst du jetzt nicht die besten deutschen Talente, aber da muss man halt den Weitblick haben. Den haben sie auch seit einigen Jahren und führen das konsequent fort.
Und wo, würdest du sagen, steht wehen Wiesbaden so im Fußball? Oder möchte man gar nicht stehen? Also dass man natürlich so weit oben spielen möchte, wie möglich, das ist ja klar. Gleichzeitig, selbst wenn man jetzt gerade im absoluten Mittelfeld der Tabelle steht, was natürlich ganz toll ist, kann man ja aber davon ausgehen, das wird sich schon noch so ein bisschen nach unten regulieren, ist zumindest zu erwarten. Aber du hast ja vorhin auch schon angedeutet, und das fand ich eben interessant, dass der Verein da so ein bisschen schwammig sei in seiner Kommunikation nach außen. Das würde mich interessieren. Also was gibt denn Wiesbaden nach außen? Was sind die Ziele eigentlich?
Ja, eigentlich kriegst du von denen nie eine gescheite Aussage. Also es war schon früher immer so, ja, so oben mitspielen oder so. Oder du denkst so, ja gut, wer will das irgendwie nicht? Das will ich nicht, aber da hab ich auch versucht, auch nachzubohren und es war dann auch, wenn ihr einen Trainer im Oktober entlasst, wenn ihr nur ein paar Punkte hinter den Aufstiegsplätzen seid, dann muss doch der Aufstieg das Ziel sein, sonst macht man das doch nicht oder so. Aber auch das, was ich an Mitmikro, ohne Mikro angesprochen geführt hab, haben alle verneint. Nee, es war jetzt kein Muss oder so. Jetzt hab ich natürlich auch wieder gefragt vor der Saison, muss ja eigentlich der Klassenerhalt das Ziel sein? Was willst du denn als letzter Aufsteiger irgendwie anderes ausgeben? Und selbst da, du hast grad Nico Schäfer erwähnt, der sagte so, na ja, will ich eigentlich gar nicht so sagen. Erst mal abwarten, wie der Start ist, und wenn man da ein paar Punkte hat, dann kann man langsam Ziel ausgeben. Und wenn wir sagen, Klassenerhalt, und wir erreichen den knapp nicht, dann sind wir ja abgestiegen, dann war das Ziel nicht gut und so. Was Klares kommt da nicht raus, wenn man fragt. Aber ich glaube, was man intern immer mal wieder hört, was sie sagen, und das ist, glaube ich, das konkreteste Ziel, was man so nennen kann, ist, dass sie gesagt haben, sie wollen zum 100-jährigen Bestehen ein etablierter Zweitligist sein. Und sie sind –du musst jetzt nicht nachgucken, ich sag's dir –1926. Und das heißt ja, da kannst du jetzt nicht nochmal absteigen, wieder aufsteigen, weil dann schaffst du das etabliert schon nicht mehr. Das heißt ja, da müssen so ein paar Klassenerhalte, was für ein lustiges Wort, ja, müssen dann jetzt nacheinander folgen. Und das ist aber, glaube ich, so das Konkreteste und was, glaube ich, den Verein auch am besten beschreibt, wenn man dieses Ziel irgendwie so erwähnt.
Und kann man auch was dazu sagen, wie, wen Wiesbaden sein möchte und wie man das erreichen möchte, weil –also grundsätzlich wollen ja alle sportlichen Erfolg, das ist klar, und man kann das auch ohne eine besondere Marke zu haben erreichen. Also das braucht man jetzt gar nicht. Aber trotzdem, wenn du eben auf der Suche nach Sponsoren bist, dann ist man ja auch in der Region, wo es ja durchaus noch andere Vereine gibt. Ich habe gehört, da soll in Mainz und in Frankfurt und in Darmstadt, da soll es da durchaus noch Teams geben. Also gibt es irgendwie so einen Markenkern, den Wiesbaden haben möchte, besonders gute Jugendarbeit, möchte man vielleicht diejenigen auffangen, die bei anderen Vereinen rausfallen, möchte man besonders innovativ sein. Ich war ehrlicherweise noch nicht mal bei euch im Schadu und deswegen kann ich wirklich gar nichts zu wehen, wie Wiesbaden sagen. Liegt das an mir? Oder hat man vielleicht auch gar nicht so ein klares Bild nach außen?
Meinst du jetzt Markenkern, wenn es darum geht, Spieler zu kriegen oder Fans? Das klang jetzt nach beidem.
Ja, also eigentlich so, was dieser Verein sein möchte, ob es da quasi etwas gibt, was es von den anderen Vereinen unterscheidet. Es kann ja auch sein, dass man einfach nur Fußball spielen will, ist ja auch völlig okay, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass man eigentlich in dieser Region ja schon ein bisschen was ausdenken muss, um Leute in den Stadion zu bekommen und eben auch einen Spieler zu bekommen. Und dann ist es ja dann doch irgendwie beides.
Da kann ich jetzt erstmal eine kleine Schnurre über das letzte Jahr machen. Da hatten sie nämlich zum Saisonstart gesagt, wir machen eine total lustige Kampagne, total kreativ haben wir uns ausgedacht, Deutschland Bester Zweitverein. Wir haben gesagt, hier ist doch nicht schlimm, wenn ihr irgendwie die oder die toll findet, kommt doch bitte auch zu uns.
Sie haben sich von David von 3.90 beraten lassen, oder?
Ja, da hat man ja gleich gemerkt, ihr wollt jetzt lustig sein, ihr wollt kreativ sein, aber eigentlich ist doch sofort auch der Gedanke, wen man damit alles verkrault. Da war natürlich die Aktive-Fans-Szene auch richtig böse. Die haben ein halbes Jahr immer wieder verschiedene Protestaktionen durchgezogen. Einmal kamen sie mit driller Pfeifen oder haben dann geschwiegen, 20 Minuten, wie auch immer. Das ist völlig in die Hose gegangen. Vielleicht zeigt es einem aber trotzdem, was sie versuchen oder was sie dann doch irgendwie sein wollen. Wir kennen das ja, man kann ja einen Verein anhängen, aber wenn man Fußball gucken will, geht man auch da und da und da ins Stadion und man freut sich einfach, live Fußball zu sehen. Das ist ja auch nichts Verwerfliches, dass sie da so ein bisschen drauf zielen. Aber ich glaube, sie wollen das jetzt kontinuierlich einfach aufbauen. Ich meine, klar, was willst du irgendwie markenkern? Auch da kann ich wieder Schäfer zitieren, der mir dann hochtrabend sagte, wir haben jetzt endlich eine Geschichte. Der Verein hat jetzt eine Geschichte. Das wissen alle, wie das war, wie wir den Aufstieg gefeiert haben und dann sind wir nicht aufgestiegen. Und dann hatten wir aber dieses Mega-Religationsspiel und die Bude war voll und dann sind wir aufgestiegen. Das ist natürlich erst mal was, was du über einen Verein erzählen kannst. Wann sich auch Leute erinnern, die jetzt, wie du sagst, die vielleicht auch noch nie im Stadion waren oder so, aber denken, ah, Wien-Wiesbaden, das war doch das und so. Und ich glaube, dass man sich da so langsam halt eine Geschichte selber aufbaut, das ist auch das, was du machen kannst. Ansonsten natürlich muss man sagen, auch wenn es um junge Talente oder so geht, dann haben natürlich andere die Nase übelst vorne. Also Wien-Wiesbaden gehört zu denen, die halt auch ihre zweite Mannschaft direkt abgeschafft haben, als man abschaffen durfte. Ja, und sie jetzt auch nicht irgendwie wieder reingeholt haben über irgendwelche komischen Umwege. Dann die U19 spielt Hessen Liga und ist jetzt glaube ich zum zweiten Mal nacheinander knapp am Aufstieg gescheitert. Die waren auch mal ein Jahr Bundesliga, weil wenn du Junior und Bundesliga spielst, dann kannst du dir auch noch mal ein paar mehr Talente locken. Also das ist nicht so einfach. Aber andererseits muss man sagen, das Stadion füllt sich jetzt langsam. Natürlich ist das immer auch durch Guest-Defense. Also wenn du gegen Schalke spielst, dann ist da ja fast die Hälfte Königsblau. Und das weißt du und damit kalkulierst du auch. Und meine Güte dafür hast du aber eine ausverkaufte Hütte und mal ein bisschen Stimmung da drin. Aber auch da, ich habe jetzt viel Vergleich zu 2019 gemacht, aber das gehört in dem Fall auch dazu. In dem Jahr, bevor Corona kam, am Ende haben sie ja umgebaut. Also da gab es ja eine Sitztribüne, gab es ja nicht. Das nimmt dir dann natürlich auch noch mal viel Potenzial weg, in der 2. Liga da Zeug zu verkaufen, Stimmung reinzubringen und so weiter. Auch da sind sie halt jetzt wirklich besser aufgestellt. Und dann werden die Zahlen auch besser.
Und dann sind wir nochmal gespannt, ob 2026 zum 100-Jährigen bestehen, wo da wen Wiesbaden steht. Also das ist wirklich interessant. Man muss das auch nicht überbewerten. Also ich frage immer so nach Strategien und so weiter. Man kann auch völlig strategielos einen Fußballverein betreiben, also nicht falsch verstehen.
Ja, sollte man nicht.
Ja, gut, aber es gibt genügend, die das machen. Aber gerade halt, wenn man in so einer Region sitzt und so weiter, will es jetzt nicht überstrapazieren. Aber deswegen hat es mich interessiert. Und vielen, vielen Dank. Jetzt habe ich schon wieder sehr, sehr viel erfahren, was ich nicht wusste. Und dann wollen wir mal noch auf den letzten verbliebenen Verein blicken. Wir gehen die Tabelle weiter. Da kommen Nürnberg, Schalke, Elbersberg, Paderborn und dann erst Benny. Aber immerhin schon Hertha BSC. Rang 15 ist man jetzt aktuell mit 6 Punkten. Und wenn ich schon in der ersten Ligatur zur zweiten Liga über einen der Absteiger spreche –und die Absteiger sind ja wirklich vorher im Rasenfunk durchgenudelt worden in den Sendungen –dann ist das meistens kein gutes Zeichen, muss man ehrlicherweise sagen. Und ich hatte das Gefühl, Hertha möchte, dass ich nicht an ihnen vorbeikomme. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo wir anfangen sollen. Ich auch nicht. Um zu erklären. Ja, ich glaube, wir müssen es einfach von vorn vorne erzählen. Was ist denn nach diesem Abstieg bei Hertha BSC passiert?
Es gab gefühlt an allen Ecken und Enden einen Umbruch. Das größte Problem war die finanzielle Lage, die so über allem schwebte. Man hat ja auch sehr lange gebraucht, bis man die Lizenz hatte. Das heißt, man konnte erst spät an anfangen mit Spieler einkaufen, aber vor allem auch Spieler verkaufen. Weil viele Clubs einfach gehofft haben, die kriegen keine Lizenz, und dann kriegen wir die Spieler ablösefrei. Also dauerte das immer noch so ein Stück. Ein paar Transfers standen schon fest, so was wie Fabian Reese, weil er schon im Januar unterschrieben hatte. Dann für den Sommer, aber sonst kam da sehr spät Bewegung rein. Dann wurde, als die Lizenz geholt wurde, war aber auch klar, okay, gut, wir müssen jetzt wirklich sehr, sehr viel Geld einsparen. Das heißt, man hat gefühlt einen Großteil der Geschäftsstelle entlassen. Zum Beispiel die CSR-Abteilung, also Corporate Social Responsibility, so ein bisschen gesellschaftliche Verantwortung, wurde komplett aufgelöst. Man hat auch an allen anderen Ecken einen Pablo Tiam, der NLZ-Leiter musste gehen, der Mediendirektor Max Jung musste gehen. Also selbst in solchen Personalien ging das am Ende nicht vorbei. Der Kader wurde komplett umgebaut. Also ich glaube, es waren irgendwie an die 40 Bewegungen, was Zugänge und Abgänge anging, dazu noch aufgefüllt mit Spielern, die teilweise aus einer Leie zurückkamen, teilweise die aus der U19 hochkamen oder aus der U23. Man hat den Jugendbereich umgekrempelt. Also da hat man gefühlt, bis auf den U19-Trainer Oliver Reis, also der U23-Trainer Ante Covic, hat die U16 übernommen. Der U16-Trainer die U17 und der U17-Trainer die U23. Also da ist so eine Rotation. Das hängt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen damit zusammen, dass Pallada und Ante Covic nicht die besten Freunde sind. Und natürlich Profi-Trainer und U23-Trainer sich dann doch ganz gut verstehen sollten. Und dann hat man noch im Kleinfeldbereich noch was. Also da hat man ein komplett neues Duo jetzt installiert für die Ausbildungs- und Spielkonzeption. Einen ehemaligen Junionspieler, der jetzt Sportwissenschaftler ist, Leo-Jonathan Tessmann und noch einen, der auch ehemals Jugendtrainer war bei Hertha, Gora Zen, der jetzt auch die U11 wieder übernommen hat. Also man hat alles Mögliche umgekrempelt. In allen möglichen Bereichen. Und dann eben vor allem den Kader, der einen großen Teil anderes Gesicht hat. Wer hätte gedacht, dass Toni Leisner auf einmal der Kapitän von Hertha sein wird. Aber das war dann eben auch einer der Transfers, die für meisten Aufsehen erregt haben, der aber inzwischen einer der größten Publikumslieblinge in dieser Mannschaft ist. Also es ist einfach grundsätzlich extrem viel passiert in diesem Verein, das kann man sagen. Aber das ist ja gefühlt bei Hertha immer. Aber dieser Umbruch war dann doch noch mal besonders groß. Das muss man wirklich sagen.
Ja, und ich fand es jetzt auch super, dass du jetzt mal so den Blick hinter die Kulissen geworfen hast. Gerade eben, wie viele Leute auf so einer Geschäftsstelle ihren Job verlieren, das ist einfach irre bei so Abstiegen, dass man dann für so etwas wie CS A dann kein Geld mehr hat. Sag vielleicht auch ein bisschen was über den Fußball, ohne dass es jetzt jemanden zum Vorwurf machen würde, weil es geht ja bei Hertha dann doch sehr schnell um die Existenz. Da muss man eben auch sehr schmerzhafte Schritte tun. Und dann war ja das, was, glaube ich, auch die Aufmerksamkeit zu groß gemacht hat. Zum einen eben, dass es Hertha BSC ist und dass man quasi wieder und wieder erst in diesem Abstieg von der Schippe gesprungen war. Und jetzt hat man halt ein paar Dardai zu spät geholt, ein paar Spieltage zu spät, deswegen hat es nicht geklappt. Aber ich glaube, das, was noch dazukam, war, dass die Themen sich miteinander vermischt haben. Also das Lizenzthema, das haben andere Zweitligisten schon ihr Training gestartet, also Hertha BSC natürlich auch. Die haben jetzt nicht mit dem Training bis dahin gewartet, aber deswegen konnte man auf dem Transfermarkt nichts tun. Und das Transferthema, auch wichtige Abgänge, wie Luque Bakuio zum Beispiel, der ja am meisten Geld noch gebracht hat, das passierte, als schon die ersten Spiele gespielt waren und die liefen halt –ich sag's wie es ist –die liefen halt scheiße, da war halt dieses 0-2-1 gegen Wehen Wiesbaden mit dabei und man hatte eben einen ganz, ganz fürchterlichen Start in diese Saison. Und trotzdem, wenn ich jetzt mit Hertha BSC-Fans spreche, dann sind die eigentlich so relativ ruhig und sagen so ja, naja, das dürfte jetzt schon werden. Was hat sich denn jetzt dann, wenn wir mal quasi mit Spieltag 1 beginnen, jetzt seitdem wieder verändert? Weil es ging ja los 0-1 gegen Düsseldorf, 0-1 gegen Wehen Wiesbaden, dann immerhin gegen Jena gewonnen. Ach ja, das war ein Pokal, ja klar, stimmt, stimmt, genau, aber das war ja eine gute Nummer, weil da hat man zum ersten Mal richtig gut gespielt, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Und dann kam die Niederlage gegen den HSV. Und mehr oder weniger nach diesem 0-3 gegen den HSV, da beginnt, glaube ich, für die meisten Hertha-Fans eigentlich wirklich die Saison einfach aus dem Grund, dass dann auch der Kader schon zum Teil stand, bzw. man einen Schritt weiter war, wirklich gestanden hat, dann vor dem Magdeburg-Spiel, also dem fünften Spieltag. Also es ist so ein bisschen vergleichbar wie mit Schalke vor zwei Jahren, wo dann auch bis kurz vor Ende dann noch so Spieler wie Arid und Nastasic und so was da rumtunten, super viel Gehalt noch gekostet haben und den Klubs so ein bisschen gelähmt haben. Und so war das halt auch mit Hertha, dass man sehr lange noch in Luka Baku noch einen Kader hatte, oder in Uremovic und so weiter. Also ein paar Spieler, bei denen klar war, die sollen eigentlich gehen oder die wollen gehen, da hängen wir noch dran. Deswegen haben, glaube ich, auch viele Fans der Mannschaft und dem Trainerteam diese ersten Niederlagen verziehen. Weil man auch sagen muss, das Düsseldorf-Spiel und das Wien-Wiesbaden-Spiel, das musst du halt eigentlich nicht verlieren. Also beide Spiele waren eigentlich so 0-0-Spiele. Dardai hat am Anfang relativ klar den Schwerpunkt auf die Defensive gelegt. Also man hat sehr defensiv auch gespielt. In den ersten Partien die Doppel-6-Bestand aus Pascha Klemens und Martin Dardai, zwei, die eigentlich Innenverteidiger waren. Das heißt, man hat irgendwie gefühlt 6 Verteidiger auf dem Platz gehabt. Und nach vorne ging nicht so viel. Man hat es über Konter hier und da versucht. Da war Riese natürlich sehr wichtig. Da gab es auch noch einen Marco Richter, bei dem man sich dann auch etwas mehr erhofft hat. Und das hat sich dann aber alles irgendwie so ein bisschen gewandelt. Das HSV-Spiel war dann wirklich desolat, muss man so sagen. Da war man komplett unterlegen. Aber dann hat sich so ein bisschen was gelöst. Auch der Verkauf von Marco Richter hat, glaube ich, Hertha auch so ein bisschen befreit. Das klingt jetzt irgendwie vielleicht gemein, aber es ist gar nicht so gemeint. Richter war einer der Spieler, bei denen Hertha gesagt hat, auf die wollen wir eigentlich setzen. Mit denen wollen wir den Kader bauen für die Zukunft. Weil Richter war jemand, der in dieser Abstiegssaison einen extrem großen Einsatz gezeigt hat. Der hat sich immer reingeworfen, der war bei den Fans deshalb auch sehr beliebt und sollte im Klub gehalten werden. Dadurch hat man versucht, ihm Wünsche zu erfüllen, wie du bekommst mehr Verantwortung. Das heißt, er wurde Kapitän in der Vorbereitung. Du darfst noch zentraler spielen, weil er gerne weg vom Flügel wollte, sondern mehr ins Zentrum. Auf einmal war so Marco Richter der Zehner von Hertha. Und dann war man halt in dieser Situation, dass er als Zehner und als Kapitän spielte und es funktionierte aber sportlich nicht. Also er hat sowohl gegen Düsseldorf als auch gegen Wiesbaden kein sonderlich gutes Spiel gemacht. Und auch gegen HSV hing er so ein bisschen in den Seilen. Gegen Jena lief es gut, da hatte man noch ein bisschen Hoffnung. Und dann kam auch dieses Angebot aus Mainz. Er wollte weg, er wollte auch die ganze Zeit weg. Das hat auch Hertha so gesagt. Das hat auch Zecke Neuendorf relativ offen auf der Saisoneröffnung gesagt, dass Richter weg will. Und ihnen halt abzugeben, hat dann dafür gesorgt, dass man aus dieser Fehlentscheidung ihm vielleicht diese Position Zentrum zuzusichern und ihm das Kapitänsamt zugeben. Das meine ich mit diesem Befreien, dass man sagen konnte, wir schauen jetzt, wer ist jetzt wirklich der Kapitän vielleicht in dieser Mannschaft. Wer will auch wirklich hier sein, wer identifiziert sich voll und ganz mit der aktuellen Lage. Und das ist eben Toni Leistner, der weiß, dass diese Mannschaft womöglich auch, oder wahrscheinlich auch noch mindestens ein Jahr in der 2. Liga spielt. Und er geht halt voran, er identifiziert sich mit dem, was der Klub will, mit diesem Berliner Weg. Das heißt, er ist auch der Leitwolf von einer sehr jungen Mannschaft. Und gleichzeitig konnte man auch positionell ein bisschen umstrukturieren, weil man nicht zwangsweise mit einem Zehner spielen musste, auch wenn er teilweise schon in so einer Achterrolle war. Aber das hat einfach so ein bisschen in dem Sinne befreit und das Ganze ein bisschen aufgelockert. Und so hat es den Hertha danach sportlich auch besser hinbekommen. Also, nachdem er in den ersten drei Spielen 0 Tore geschossen hat, erfolgten dann 5, 4 und 3 Tore. Also, genau.
Also ein 5 zu 0 gegen Gräuterfurt, dann ein 4 zu 6 bei Magdeburg. Das haben sicherlich viele Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen. Und dann jetzt eben am Wochenende ein 3 zu 0 gegen Eintracht Braunschweig. Dann lass mal ein bisschen auf den Kader blicken. Den Witz, den habe ich ja auch schon gerne genommen im Rasenfunk, gefühlt besteht die halbe Mannschaft aus Dardais. Wie wird denn das eigentlich aufgenommen, dass nicht nur der Trainer bei Hertha so eine wichtige Figur spielt, sondern auch –sind das jetzt alle seiner Söhne? Hat er noch weitere Söhne? Dürfen wir uns dann noch auf mehr freuen? Wie kommt das bei Hertha-Fans an?
Er hat nur die drei, aber tatsächlich gibt es in der U17 noch Patrice Čović, den Sohn von Ante Čović.
Ja gut, der Hertha hat dann keine Chance, wenn die sich nicht mögen.
Nee, also es sind alle drei. Also unter den Fans war es eine Zeit lang sehr zwiegespalten, so habe ich das wahrgenommen. Also gerade nach den Nierlagen war dann natürlich sofort, aber Hauptsache, die Söhne haben gespielt und so weiter. Bei manchen, also das will ich auch gar nicht sagen, das haben jetzt irgendwie alle gesagt, sondern ein Großteil hat das auch klar verteidigt, weil es natürlich auch sportlich klar Grüne für sie gab. Marthon Dardai hat U21-EM gespielt, Bence Dardai wird von halb Europa gescoutet, berichten zufolge bis hin zu Juventus Turin. Und auch sein Vater, also der Trainer, hat das auch angedeutet, dass es namhafte Clubs gab, die Interesse hatten. Und ein Palko Dardai, den hat man für einen schmalen Taler von einer niedrigen sechsstelligen Summe aus Ungarn zurückholen können. Und er ist halt natürlich einer, der sich voll und ganz mit diesem Club identifiziert und eine gewisse Variabilität reinbringt. Das heißt, der hat zu Beginn noch auf rechts außen gespielt, zum Beispiel auch gegen Wiesbaden noch. Ist dann aber auch ins Zentrum gerückt zuletzt. Hat sich jetzt gegen Braunschweig am Wochenende verletzt. Aber es gab sportlich zumindest viele Gründe, warum die spielen. Benz Dardai, also der Jüngste, ist auch eigentlich mehr in der Joker-Rolle und ist in die auch reingerutscht, weil es einfach personell sehr dünn besetzt ist, das offensive Mittelfeld, wo er herkommt. Weil der, der eigentlich dahin vorgesehen war, war Ibrahim Masa. Der hat auch schon am letzten Bundesligaspieltag z.B. gegen Wolfsburg getroffen. Da erinnert sich vielleicht die eine oder andere Zuhörer. Der hat sich aber leider in der Vorbereitung schwer verletzt, fällt ein paar Monate aus. Dann gab es eben Marco Richter, der war weg, und auf einmal blieben dann eigentlich nur noch so Palko Dardai, der dort auch eingesetzt wurde, und eben Bence, so ein zentraler offensiver Mittelfeldspieler übrig. Sodass es in dem Sinne auch positive Gründe gab, warum Bence immer wieder eingewechselt wird. Und Marthorn war eben der einzig gefühlt gelernte, halbwegs gelernte Mittelfeldspieler, den man im Kader hatte. Das der gespielt hat, war auch wenig überraschend, vor allem weil er mit seiner Passqualität dann doch für eine gewisse Kreativität nach vorne sorgen konnte. Auch wenn die auch begrenzt war, weil es einfach überhaupt keine Bindung gab, keine Box-to-Box-Spieler. Und es fies so eine Art große Lücke im Zentrum gab, auch im Spiel nach vorne. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine mediale, eine größere Diskussion. Da hat sich auch Pall Dardai dann ziemlich auf einer Pressekonferenz mal eschöpiert, weil es in der Sport-Bild einen großen Bericht darüber gab, dass es angeblich in der Mannschaft nicht so gern gesehen wird. Und so weiter. Und da es kritische Stimmen gab, dann hat Pall Dardai sehr lange ausgeholt und eine sehr ausführliche Rede dazu gehalten. Er hat von Anfang an gesagt, wenn sich auch nur ein Spieler hier unwohl fühlt oder das irgendwer im Klub wahrnimmt, dann würde er sofort zurücktreten, weil er das nicht will. Und er hätte in dieser Mannschaft 24 Söhne oder so. Da hat er gesagt, also hat ihm die Anzahl der Spieler, die alle im Kader sind, gesagt. Und ich glaube auch, dass das Thema weitaus geringer geworden ist, einfach weil es sportlich wenig Gründe gibt, die nicht spielen zu lassen.
Okay, damit haben wir die Hälfte des Kaders analysiert, nämlich alle Dardai-Söhne. Es tut mir leid, ich kann keine Anhörungen aufhören. Ein bisschen lustig ist es schon. Das haben wir einfach nicht so oft.
Es ist auch in dem Sinne –sorry, dass ich nochmal unterbreche –ganz lustig, die haben auch ähnliche Rückennummern. Und dadurch hast du, wenn du im Stadion bist, wäre Harris Tabakovic nicht da. Und alle drei würden spielen, wären nacheinander Palko, Benze und die Reihenfolge wäre Benze, Palko und dann Marthorn Dardai. Und so hast du jetzt Tabakovic mit der 25 sozusagen noch zwischen Benze und Palko, sonst hättest du dreimal in Folge Dardai.
Ja, Mensch, es ist eigentlich schade, könnte der Stadionsprecher sich ja Zeit sparen und einfach sagen, und jetzt mit der 39, 40 und 41. Also das sind die falschen Nummern, aber ja, gut. Aber so ist es jetzt nicht. Jetzt habe ich schon gelernt, also Toni Leistner spielt eine wichtige Rolle. Wer Toni Leistner so ein bisschen verfolgt hat, den wundert das auch nicht so ganz. Das war ein Transfer, wo ich mir gleich gedacht habe, boah, das könnte richtig gut passen. Und ich hatte auch das Gefühl, da hat sich jemand auf 2. Liga eingestellt, also bei Hertha BSC. Wer sind denn sonst noch so wichtige Spieler aktuell im Kader?
Ich würde sagen auf jeden Fall Michael Karbovnik. Einfach weil Dardai sehr großen Wert legt, mindestens einen spielstarken Außenverteidiger im Kader zu haben. Dardai öffnet das Spiel gerne über die defensiven Außen. Also er hat zum Beispiel früher, als es Oma Alderete noch im Kader gab, der gerne als Innenverteidiger das Spiel durchs Zentrum gemacht hat, hat er ihm sehr oft gesagt, ich will nicht, dass du das Spiel über das Zentrum aufmachst, einfach wegen des hohen Risikos, was er da sieht. Und früher hatte Hertha, man erinnert sich vielleicht an Spieler wie Mitchell Weiser oder Valentino Lazaro, die halt über die Außenverteidigerposition, also Weiser war lange der Spielmacher von Hertha als Rechtsverteidiger. Und genau das hat Hertha in den ersten Spielen so ein bisschen gefehlt. Man hatte zwar Jeremy Dudziak schon, der das auch wirklich gut macht und der auch gut reinpasst, aber der dann teilweise auch hier und da mal im Mittelfeld gebraucht worden ist. Und dann hatte man auf den Außenverteidigerpositionen dann auf einmal wieder Spieler wie Pekarek oder John-Jo Kenny rechts hinten, der gespielt hat, weil sich Seevolk am ersten Spieltag verletzt hat. Und Kenny ist spielerisch auch limitiert. Und dann kam Karbovnik, macht sein erstes Spiel und man merkt sofort einen kompletten Unterschied, weil er diese Pressing-Resistenz hat und dann einfach mal einen Gegenspieler vorbei dribbelt. Und dann das Spiel sozusagen ein bisschen beschleunigen kann für Hertha und man nicht so sehr unter dem hohen Druck liegt. Das heißt, der ist meiner Meinung nach ein sehr wichtiger Spieler. Ich fand den Transfer auch –Fabian Reese ist immens wichtig, das muss man einfach sagen, weil er mit seinen Sprints, der ist der Spieler in der Liga mit den meisten Sprints, der ist bei Hertha auch –das wird nicht überraschend –auch mit den meisten intensiven Läufen. Einer, der sich sehr viel selber traut, der auch sehr viel den Ball fordert, der mit Leidenschaft vorweggeht, also der einen Freistoß bejubelt, einen Elfmeterpfiff bejubelt als besten Tor, der sich auch sehr schnell, wenn man sich seinem Instagram-Profil anschaut, mit der Stadt Berlin identifiziert hat.
Also, mit Berlin sich identifizieren können ja ehrlicherweise in alle Richtungen gehen, von Großkriminalität bis hin zu ich bin gerne im Tierpark.
Er ist mehr so diese, wie soll ich sagen, diese Hipster-Ecke. Also, Fabian Reese postet auch gerne an welchem Flohmarkt er in diesem Wochenende mit seiner Freundin Klamotten verkauft und die Leute können gerne vorbeikommen. Und er posiert für Magazin-Fotos oder für Instagram-Fotos gerne vor Berliner Ur-Berliner Kneipen. Ja, das ist so das Ding hier. Hört techno auf, boten auf der Spree und so weiter.
Also quasi wie so ein Politikstudent aus Berlin.
Genau, so kann man das sagen. Der war jetzt einfach immens wichtig. Er schlägt auch, wie schon im letzten Jahr, bei Kiel die meisten Flanken auch in der ganzen Liga geschlagen, mit Abstand. Und das tut aber Hertha auch wieder. Also der belebt das alles sehr in der Offensive, auch weil er mit seinem Tempo da unglaublich wichtig ist, dass man ihn einfach mal schicken kann. Einfach mal den Ball blind hinschlagen und irgendwie wäre er zumindest darum kämpfen, den zu bekommen. Der ist sehr wichtig. Und da muss man einfach Haris Tabakovic erwähnen, der natürlich der auffälligste Mann ist, alleine weil er jetzt so viele Tore geschossen hat. Der ist einfach immens wichtig, alleine weil er so einen guten Wandstürmer hatte, der hatte lange nicht mehr. Ich glaube, der letzte war John Cordoba, der aber jedes zweite Spiel verletzt war. Aber Tabakovic kannst du immer anspielen und der macht den Ball fest. Es gab für mich eine irre Statistik in dem Magdeburg-Spiel. Da hatte Daniel Heber von Magdeburg, der Innenverteidiger, 12 Zweikämpfe gewonnen und damit die meisten bei Magdeburg. Auf der anderen Seite war es Tabakovic mit 24, also doppelt so viele. Und es waren fast alles diese Zweikämpfe. Die Gegner treibt die regelmäßig in die Verzweiflung, weil einfach jeden Ball festmacht und die den Ball nicht abnehmen kann mit dem Rücken zum Tor. Und dieses Element, das im Spiel sehr wichtig ist, weil der Hertha sehr schnell mit den Flügeln Reese und Winkel aufrückt, Palco Dardai zuletzt nachzieht übers Zentrum. Und schon warst du sehr schnell, oder auch Karbovnik und Dudziak, die werden auch mal geschickt, Spiele, die nachrücken können, und dann kommen die Flanken rein. Und jetzt hast du in der Mitte jemanden, der die auch abnimmt. Also diese Reese-Flanken finden jetzt jemanden. In den ersten Spieltagen –ich erinnere mich an das Wiesbaden-Spiel –Florian Nierlechner war da einfach nicht der Stürmertyp für. Der stand dann eben nicht da, wo dann Reese hinflankte. Und jetzt hast du Tabakovitsch dort im Zentrum, der die Bälle verwertet, der sehr effektiv ist und der auch mit einer gewissen Leidenschaft einfach auch vorweggeht und bei den Fans schon den Spitznam Fluppe bekommen hat. Und jetzt auch am Wochenende habe ich schon die ersten Fußballgottrufe gehört.
Der ja auch so ein bisschen ein gutes Licht wirft auf den neuen Sportdirektor Benjamin Weber. Also Tabakovitsch ist jetzt kein 18-jähriges Talent. Der ist 29, glaube ich, und kommt von Austria, Wien. Also da hätten auch andere darauf aufmerksam werden können. Jetzt hatten wir sehr, sehr viel Umbruch im Kader mit sehr vielen Abgängen und eben auch sehr vielen Neuzugängen. Was würdest du denn sagen, kennzeichnet diese erste, richtige Transferperiode von Benjamin Weber, außer dass er diesen Tabakovitsch, die er durchgezogen hat, obwohl sein Handyakku zwischendurch leer gegangen ist, ihn wohl ein bisschen in den Schwitzen gebracht hat?
Ja, das fand ich auch ganz, ganz lustig. Ich glaube, der Hauptpunkt ist wirklich, was Hertha wichtig war, war, dass es möglichst alle Spieler sind, die sich voll und ganz mit dem Verein auch identifizieren können, die sich da reinwerfen und auch mit Leidenschaft vorangehen, weil man zu oft in den letzten Jahren irgendwie gesagt hat, man kauft Spieler mit Mentalität, aber dann irgendwie es dann doch relativ schnell irgendwie eingeknickt ist, so in dem Sinne. Also Ivan Szunyuc war zum Beispiel so jemand, der wurde eben genau geholt mit, der ist einer, der ist eklig, der ist dreckig auf dem Platz, der kämpft dann, aber dann kommt er bei dem ersten Dardai-Training schon nicht mehr klar und lässt sich irgendwie hängen. Wilfried Congar hat sich irgendwie dann doch enttäuschend oft im Spiel hängen lassen. Und ich glaube, was den Leuten in der Geschäftsstelle wichtig war, war, dass es Spieler sind, die sich voll und ganz identifizieren können, worum es für Hertha geht. Und das ist nicht unbedingt direkt der Aufstieg, sondern das ist daran, jetzt sportlich eine gewisse Identität auch zu entwickeln, unter Dardai fleißig zu sein. Das ist immer sein Lieblingswort. Er will eine fleißige Mannschaft und die Mannschaft, die er zum Ende der Bundesliga vorgefunden hat, war nicht fleißig. Die neue Mannschaft ist es, das lobt er immer wieder. Und das ist so ein Punkt plus. Man muss jetzt auch wieder mehr mit dem Ball selber machen. Man weiß einfach, dass man häufig in eine Favoritenrolle rückt. Das heißt, auch eine gewisse Kreativität in den Kader geholt. Mit Dudziak, mit Karbovnik. Das sind solche Spieler, die man da nennen kann. Und das würde ich so erwähnen. Einfach auch eine gewisse Achse zu schaffen, auf die man sich verlassen kann über ein Jahr hinaus. Da ist Toni Leist ein Faktor, da ist auch Andreas Buchalakis, den man noch am vorletzten Transfertag geholt hat aus Pireus. Der war mal Kapitän bei Olympiakos Pireus vor nicht allzu langer Zeit, vor zwei, drei Jahren. Der ist sofort im Mittelfeld ein Führungsspieler. Auch Fabian Reese ist jemand, der gerne an diesem Team Verantwortung übernimmt. Das ist etwas, wo man eine Achse mit Marius Gersbeck aufbauen wollte. Das hat aus bekannten Gründen nicht ganz geklappt. Aber da hat man ein gewisses Führungsvakuum, das bei Hertha die letzten Jahre war. Seitdem man einen Sommer Spieler wie Ibiscevic und Skjelbrit verloren hat, hat man versucht, das mit Spielern aufzufüllen, die gerne Verantwortung übernehmen und die nicht unter dem Druck der Verantwortung schwächer werden. Bei Hertha war es oft so, dass sobald jemand die Kapitänsbinde angezogen hat, war er nur noch 80 Prozent so gut wie eigentlich. Toni Leissner ist eben genau das Gegenteil davon. Der blüht auch mit dieser Binde auf und der ist das gewohnt aus den letzten Jahren. Darunter sammeln sich dann auch mehrere weitere Führungsspieler, die gerne vorangehen. Das tut dem Verein ganz gut.
Das bringt mich zur letzten Frage, Benny. Wie ist die Stimmung im Umfeld? Beziehungsweise Sonja möchte noch etwas sagen.
Ich hoffe, ich nehme dir da nichts weg. Wenn ich es jetzt frage, ob es im Umfeld ist, ist es etwas anderes. Ich wollte mal fragen, wie du den Trainer wahrnimmst. Ich wollte jetzt nicht sagen, wie du Dardai wahrnimmst. Sonst können wir über ganz viele verschiedene Dinge reden, um da mal bei den schlechten Witzen einfach mitzumachen. Nein, wie du Paul Dardai wahrnimmst. Was ich so von ihm mitbekommen habe, ich glaube, es war nach dem Fürth-Spiel, da hat er sich bei Sky hingestellt. Im Interview fand ich ihn irgendwie arg Drama-Queen. Mit seinem, wir waren gar nicht so schlecht, wie ihr alle gesagt habt. Wir haben es eben schon besprochen, was Hertha die ersten Spiele so gebracht hat. Ich kann gerade von dem Wiesbaden-Spiel sagen, da passte noch nicht viel zusammen. Da hätte er einfach sagen können, ihr kennt ja alle die Vorgeschichte, der Kader steht noch nicht so. Da wir Tabakovic jetzt hatten, der kam gegen Wiesbaden das erste Mal rein und hat ja schon angedeutet, was da gehen kann mit einem Latten-Treffer, der auch so gut das Siegthof von Hertha hätte sein können. Aber dass Erich dann da hinstellt und irgendwie so, da hat er versucht so Statistiken zu bemühen, die ich gar nicht so richtig nachvollziehen konnte. Das fand ich eine einigermaßen seltsame Reaktion. Wenn du jetzt auch noch was sagst, dass Erdan schon wieder sagt, wenn da irgendetwas nicht passt, dann trete ich zurück. Das ist ja sowieso so ein bisschen sein Kern. Das ist ja nicht das erste Mal, dass er das so formuliert.
Ich bin nur der kleine Pahl. Ich kann auch wieder die U23 trainieren.
Ja, so ist es ja unterhaltsam für uns. Aber jetzt hätte ich gerne mal deine Sicht dazu.
Gute Frage. Ich nehme ihn auch etwas dünnhäutig wahr, muss ich sagen. Also es war bei Hertha oft so, dass Dardai eigentlich immer sehr locker war und immer einen Spruch auf den Lippen hatte. Also hat er irgendwie dann einen Finger an, mal seine Spieler mit Tieren zu vergleichen. Oder keine Ahnung, dass er nach einer Pressekonferenz in Hoffenheim erstmal den besten Milchreis seines Lebens gelobt hat. Und solche Sachen. Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass er selber –er hat ja auch schon gesagt, er nimmt das teilweise als Mobbing wahr, was passiert in den Medien und sowas, was ich gar nicht so extrem finde. Weil es ist mehr oder weniger eigentlich Springer, mit denen er sich anlegt. Und es sind nicht die Medien so, sondern es ist ein Medienhaus, mit dem er nicht ganz konform geht. Weil ich finde nicht, dass man in den anderen Medien gelesen hat, dass Hertha als Aufstiegsfavorit sofort gesprochen wird. Es ist eher so ein erweiterten Kreis. Und Dardai behauptet, dass alle gesagt hätten, dass Hertha sofort aufsteigen müsste. Und er hat immer gesagt, es wird schwer. Und dabei haben eigentlich die meisten, auch bei den Fans, die Erwartung nicht. Wir steigen sofort wieder auf, weil man genau weiß, dass es ganz anders war. Deswegen nehme ich ihn auf jeden Fall dünnhäutig wahr. Er hat dann auch wieder Tage, wo er sehr locker ist. Es ist so ein bisschen hin und her. Man merkt einfach, manche Themen nerven ihn sehr. Das ist immer mit seinen Söhnen. Weil er nicht will, dass sie als seine Söhne betitelt werden, sondern dass auch gesagt wird, hier, das ist Marthorn Dardai, das ist Palko Dardai, das ist Bence Dardai und nicht, dass gesagt wird, ihr Sohn Bence, ihr Sohn Marthorn, ihr Sohn Palko. Das ist ihm wichtig, damit die nicht einfach wie ein Spieler beschrieben werden, als wäre es ein Fabian Rehse, als wäre es ein Smile, Préviac, wie auch immer. Und da reagiert er dann gerne mal sehr dünnhäutig. Und ich finde, wo ich dir auch recht gebe, ich war auch verblüfft von diesem Sky-Interview, weil ich fand das Hertha spielerisch auch gegen Düsseldorf und gegen Wiesbaden. Da waren sie ja defensiv ganz gut, aber offensiv war das jetzt auch wirklich nicht spektakulär. Also da hat man sich nicht so viel herausgespielt. Aber ich glaube, dass er, er will halt auch nicht diesen Stempel als Defensiv-Trainer haben, weil er, glaube ich, dieses Jahr auch offensiver spielen will. Also er spricht gerne dann auf einmal davon, dass er so den Traum hat von einer Mannschaft mit vollen fluiden Positionen in der Offensive. Hat dann von einem U17-Turnier, wo er mal Trainer war, bei Hertha rezitiert, wo er meinte, er hätten alle in der D4-5-Offensivspieler, hätten alle total fluide mal von rechts ins Zentrum, dann nach links und so. Und nur die Verteidiger hatten wirklich klare Positionen. Und dass er sich das auch langfristig für Hertha wünschen würde. Und er hat ja auch schon in der früheren Zeit mal davon gesprochen, dass er als Hertha so ein neues Ajax gerne machen will. Und ich glaube, deswegen sind diese Punkte. Er will nicht als Defensivtrainer abgestempelt werden. Und er will nicht als Vater von drei Spielern abgestempelt werden. Und ich glaube, sobald es in diese Themen geht, wird er dann etwas sensibler und dann auch etwas aggressiver nach außen oder etwas klarer und stellt sich dann ganz klar vor die Mannschaft, vor den Verein und dann lieber eine Spur Hertha als eine Spur Schwächer, um da vielleicht mal so ein bisschen manche zu bremsen in der Berichterstattung. Weil er das, ja, es wirkt schon teilweise wie ein Clinch auch zwischen Hertha und der Bild, muss man einfach auch so sagen.
Also, und wenn was passt zu Pardadai, dann ja wohl, wenn eine Spur Hertha. Du hast den einfach so nebenher gemacht. Ich habe den jetzt einfach nur verwertet.
Ich habe in deinem Gesichtsausdruck gesehen, was ich gesagt habe.
Ja, das ist der Nachteil von Video. Ihr wusstet alle, was kommt. Allerletzte Frage, wir haben es schon ein bisschen überzogen, aber ich kann es nicht weglassen. Die Stimmung im Umfeld, denn habe ich das richtig gehört, Dauerkartenrekord oder zumindest sehr, sehr viele Dauerkarten verkauft. Und das ja auch schon quasi, als es schlecht lief. Also man hat jetzt nicht nur gewartet auf das 5-0 gegen Fürth und dann haben alle gesagt, ah, jetzt ist Hertha gut, sondern es scheint mir, das, was wir alles als sehr großes Drama wahrgenommen haben, von außen und auch als die Möglichkeit, vielleicht rutscht Hertha sogar durch in die dritte Liga. Also zumindest hat es jetzt nicht die Fans daran gehindert, Tickets zu kaufen.
Also der Zuschausschnitt liegt bei fast 40.000, obwohl die Gegner bisher Fürth, Braunschweig und Wien-Wiesbaden waren. Und da noch kein Schalke, kein Magdeburg, kein Rostock, kein St. Pauli dabei war. Oder der HSV, wo wahrscheinlich noch weitaus mehr kommen werden. Ich glaube einfach, dass viele sich mit diesem Berliner Weg sehr gut identifizieren können. Bei Hertha träumt man immer von dieser, oder denkt gerne zurück an diese Generation mit Kevin Prinz, Boateng, Patrick Ebert und Co. Das waren Leute, mit denen man sich komplett identifizieren kann. Das waren die Berliner Straßenkids, die anders Fußball gespielt haben, ein bisschen erfrischend waren für die Mannschaft. Und jetzt hat man wieder diesen Berliner Weg mit vielen jungen Spielern im Kader. Ich glaube, ich habe mir aufgeschrieben, es waren 11, 12 oder 13 Spieler, die unter 23 sind, die jetzt schon gespielt haben in diese Zeit. Nicht alle aus der eigenen Jugend, aber sehr viele Junge. Man unterstützt diese Mannschaft auch sehr gerne, weil man weiß, die brauchen auch die Fans. Und die kämpfen auch für diese Fans. Die haben richtig Bock drauf. Robert Quasi-Groch, die eigentliche Nummer 2, der durfte jetzt gegen Braunschweig spielen, weil Tjag Ernst einen Magen-Darm-Infekt hatte. Der hat nach dem Spiel geweint, weil er so glücklich war, dass er im Olympiastadion mal ein Spiel spielen durfte. Ich glaube, das sind die Szenen, die dann komplett emotionalisieren und auch dafür sorgen, dass die Identifikation zwischen Mannschaft und Fans, wonach sie die Fans jahrelang gesehen haben, eine Mannschaft, mit der sie sich identifizieren können und die nicht wieder nächstes Jahr alle weggehen wollen, das ist ein Faktor, der eine große Rolle spielt. Dann weiß man auch um diese schwierige finanzielle Lage und will diesen Verein an allen möglichen Punkten unterstützen. Das ist, glaube ich, dann auch noch mal ein Faktor, der eine Rolle spielt.
Ja, die Hertha-Fans waren schon immer da, wenn man sie gebraucht hat. Den Fans konnte man eigentlich nie etwas vorwerfen. Klar kann man mal diskutieren, ob es jetzt hilfreich ist, knapp 20-Jährigen die Trikots abzunehmen nach einem verlorenen Derby. Aber mit solchen Ausnahmen, ansonsten stabile Kurve, würde ich sagen, auch im ganzen Engagement, was über den Fußball hinausgeht. Also das CSA, die Fans werden es weitermachen, die Aktionen für Obdachlose usw. Selbst wenn der Verein das jetzt nicht mehr machen kann. Ihr drei, irgendwie könnte ich noch lange mit euch sprechen. Eigentlich wollte ich mit euch auch noch allgemein über die Liga sprechen. Aber das stecken wir uns jetzt einfach, weil wir haben so viel gelernt. Aber ich bin sehr, sehr dankbar, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Ich habe sehr aufmerksam vorhin in Piekes Augen geforscht, bei jeder Erwähnung von Fabian Reese. Aber ich habe da keinen großen Schmerz erkannt. Also ich glaube, du bist darüberhin weggekommen.
Tatsächlich war er ein Spieler, der ersetzbar war. Zumindestens von seiner Effektivität. Er war ein Spieler, der immer, wie Benni auch meinte, der ackert, der zieht die Abwehr auf sich, der rennt, egal wie viele Minuten, egal wie doll man zurück lag. Der hat immer alles gegeben. Und auch schon bei Kiel so die kleinen Dinge im Spiel direkt gefeiert, immer wieder die Kurve angeheizt. Aber er hat die meisten Flanken geschlagen, aber auch davon sehr wenig an Mann gebracht.
Ja, die meisten Flanken, es muss kein Qualitätssiege sein.
Genau.
Pike, da hast du dich jetzt nochmal mit einer letzten Einschätzung quasi selbst nochmal verabschiedet. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk. Alle, die sagen, ey, das war ja viel zu wenig zu Kiel, ja, dann hört mal 1912 FM, da kann man dich ja auch hören. Danke, dass du hier warst.
Danke für die Einladung.
Und danke, ich freue mich sehr, Sonja, dass wir jetzt auch über den Wiesbaden gesprochen haben. Wenn wir es auch noch irgendwann schaffen, über den ESC zu sprechen, dann haben wir, glaube ich, sobald alle Themen abgedeckt sind, bei denen du volle Kompetenz ausdrehst. Danke dir, Sonja, dass du mit dabei warst.
Ja, danke dir. Dann die Sonderfolge Rasenfunk meets ESC.
Ja, eigentlich zusammen mit Tobias Escher müsste man schon mal –eigentlich ist das ein Livestream. Seien wir ehrlich, das ist ein Livestream. Aber mal gucken.
Ja, Livestream ist schwierig, aber ich arbeite da ja auch immer.
Ach ja, stimmt, genau.
Wir können den nicht zusammen gucken oder so. Wir könnten irgendwie so real live gucken.
Ob das im real life funktioniert, weiß ich nicht. Aber ja, stimmt, du bist natürlich da immer unterwegs. Auf bleistiftrocker.de heißt deine Seite, wo man all die Texte dazu lesen kann. Kann ich sehr empfehlen. Ist ja überhaupt nicht meine Musik, was so beim ESC läuft, außer irgendwelche Norweger Schickmieder-Metal-Bands. Dann bin ich auch mit dabei. Aber ich habe schon so manches bei dir gelesen. Einfach nur, weil es mich dann doch interessiert hat. Also sehr schöne Texte.
Stichwort Lesen vielleicht noch, weil du es vorhin in der Einleitung nicht gesagt hast. hessenschau.de gibt es natürlich von mir Berichte über den SVB in Wiesbaden. Also du hast jetzt nicht gesagt, wo das herkommt, dass ich mich für den Verein beschäftige. Aber das ist hauptsächlich für den HR.
Ja, stimmt, sehr gut. Ach, das ist so schön. Ich muss meinen Job ja gar nicht machen. Ihr übernehmt das schon für mich. Und ihr macht auch für mich die Wortspiele, die ich dann nur noch aufnehmen muss. Das hat mir Benjamin Zurmühl in diesem Fall gemacht. Danke dir, Benni, dass du mal wieder hier warst. War sehr interessant, mit dir über HTA BSC zu sprechen. Also, ich habe damit keine Probleme. Und so wie ich die Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und –Hörer kenne, wird das für die auch in Ordnung gewesen sein. Herzlichen Dank euch dreien. Und herzlichen Dank euch da draußen für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Im Rasenfunk haben wir wahnsinnig viele Folgen veröffentlicht. Also, ihr könnt ja was hören zur Frauen-Bundesliga, zur Männer-Bundesliga, zum europäischen Fußball. Klickt euch einfach mal auf rasenfunk.de und dann durch die Sendung. Wenn ihr da nichts findet, was euch nicht ein bisschen interessiert, dann seid ihr das Problem und nicht der Rasenfunk. So offensiv kann ich das jetzt formulieren. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.
Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr Knausa.